as you just saw president from wrapping
up a speech to steel workers in Illinois
just moments ago
he's also visited farmers in Iowa that
was earlier today we had this hat made
up look at that it's the John Deere
colors actually but make our farmers
great again as they make basically we
opened up Europe and that's gonna be a
great thing for Europe and it's really
gonna be a great thing for us and it's
gonna be a really great thing for our
farmers
after years of shutdowns and cutbacks
today the blast furnace here in Granite
City is blazing bright workers are back
on the job and we are once again pouring
new American steel into the spine of our
country now some people are saying one
of the biggest problems for Democrats in
2018 this year and 2020 the presidential
election year is the party's inability
to develop a cohesive message to counter
President Trump in fact an op-ed in the
New York Times today foreshadows Trump
winning re-election in 2020 due to the
strong economy senator Elizabeth Warren
who is rumored to be a future possible
opponent of the president's offered a
much different approach than Trump he or
she is calling for higher taxes there
was a time in a very prosperous America
an America that was growing the middle
class in America in which working
families were doing better generation
after generation after generation where
the top marginal rate was well above 50%
so Jessie I think the president and
Republicans want to talk about the
economy about the stock market doing
Welli they've had some trouble
delivering the message on the benefits
of the tax cut but we see the president
getting out there and this may be the
message he wants to deliver going into
the midterms first of all I want that
green hat that looks pretty good
wait wait wait it would cover up our
wonderful you did just get your haircut
that's true you know what I don't waste
money
I think I think Trump leads to focus
like a laser on the economy and law and
order and judges and keep hammering
Democrats as socialist freaks who knew
during the national anthem there are
great headlines coming out of the
economy we're supposed to get an
enormous GDP number tomorrow maybe three
four five percent we've had three
straight quarters of 3% GDP economic
growth and the low unemployment
fantastic for everyone in the tax cut
has delivered a $2,600 cut to every
family in this country but there are
areas of concern the wages dipped a
little bit the last quarter they're
still up 2.8 percent we're under Obama
they were flat and the trade deal is
tough because you know you see some
places like we're talking about you know
if steel companies closing and then you
have aluminum companies opening up and
what he did with the EU was actually
very smart I think what he did is he's
saying for short-term pain we want
long-term gains so he raised some
tariffs and they came back begging
yesterday and they have a verbal deal
and they're gonna now drop the tariffs
on non industrial goods they're gonna
drop the tariffs on liquefied natural
gas we still have the auto tariffs in
play which isn't good for Michigan and
South Carolina but all in all you know
the the the farm subsidies I think are
good politics but bad economics but it's
just showing the trade partners listen
we're gonna soften the blow because
you're not going to inflict any pain on
us and in order to eventually bring down
all trade barriers and that's the goal
free and open and fair trade okay so
Dana Jesse makes the case I think from
the Trump perspective that you want your
partner's I think the president said his
favorite word is reciprocal SIP Racal
but here's the thing
in the papers today it said my little
pony Jack Daniels coca-cola GM the
farmers and whirlpool all say you know
what this is hurting us hurting our
profits it is and I think that's one of
the reasons you saw the president one be
conciliatory towards the EU yesterday
it's just good for our allies for us to
work together they didn't actually agree
to anything yesterday they just agreed
to stop fighting in public and to deal
with the issues and I think that's great
because we need to fight as allies
against countries like China I think
that the president is smart to get out
of town if went in the early years of
the Bush administration that first term
the economy was great you could not get
a lot of media coverage around it
obviously we were at war as well the
the great thing for the president if he
wants good headlines is he has to go to
these places and watch where the
president goes he's going to places
where he can help vulnerable Republican
members
he went to Iowa today in Illinois
there's two members there Republicans
that are in very bad shape and he wanted
to go and help shore them up he'll
probably return to those places the
other thing I would say is getting that
Wisconsin Minnesota in Michigan all of
his numbers there are really bad and so
the where these tariff issues should
help should be there they're not helping
so much so he's got to figure out how to
figure out how to turn that around and
by being conciliatory towards the EU he
might be able to do that Greg how did
you get back from Granite City so
quickly well you know I have a private
plane oh you know it's like looking at
Liz Warren and other folks like Cory
Booker right now that we have so much
good news so much good news and the dams
are fixated on finding bad news they're
like there was old strange men on the
beach with metal detectors you know that
always will walk in too close to you
yeah hoping to find something except
their misery detectors and they can't
find any misery so they have to invent
misery in this case Liz Warren wants to
raise tax rates to 50% for people for
some people in rollback the tax cuts
she's essentially a success extinguisher
she's looking at the economy like it's a
fire and she wants to put it out that's
what she's doing so here's what I worry
about is that there might achieve
something what I've noticed is that we
might be entering the second part of a
political cycle that's been going on for
the since the 60s the Republicans come
in and they fix things and then that
allows the Democrats to come in and
break things because there are things to
be broken and then you forget the
Republicans back in to fix things
because the Democrats broke things
and the Republicans fix things and then
the public says oh now we can sustain
more Democrats so they come in to break
things and this goes back for some
Republicans fix Democrats break
Republicans fix Democrats break this has
been going on since the 1960s so now
Trump is fixed a half a dozen things and
everybody's going hey you know what
let's give those Democrats another
chance let it break some stuff we can't
let them break it but it's a Dana's
point too you know he is there because
of vulnerable
members of Congress but he's also
talking to I think key constituencies
right now talking to steel workers and
farmers because there are people that
have felt the effect of this you know
trade tariffs that are going back and
forth and so I think his message to them
both with the farmers and the steel
workers is I'm with you I was with you
because you were the Forgotten men and
woman who President Obama left behind
and I'm standing with you now and I'm
fighting for you and so I think it's a
really critical time for him to be
sending that message and also to be
touting the fact that we have seen
hundreds of thousands of manufacturing
jobs added under President Trump the
economy is good one because Jesse
pointed out GDP growth tomorrow one
quick question okay the deficit because
he's offering 12 billion in subsidies to
the farmers and even the farmers are
like boy you know with the tax cut that
didn't pan out and now this that blows
up the debt they used to be a Republican
thing no wasn't a Democrat thing I said
Republic I know but I mean Democrats
didn't care about deficit oh you guys
invented him hard
I'm not down with the bailout but I
think President Trump can say that I'm
fighting with for you and yesterday's
press conference also came at a critical
time for him to be able to say that look
this is having a movement and a fault